we had a whole lot of love I love Matt a
bomb sort of
I was completely bombed but it just got
dropped and two people completely
paralyzed by their inability to
communicate and remove themselves from a
toxic situation Adam this is your
bachelor season 24 episode 8 hometowns
baby recap grab your glasses it's time
for roses and rosey hi everybody it's me
Lauren Zima and I am sparkling out of
the darkness I'm talking about the
bedazzled stones on this sweater and of
course using them as a metaphor for the
darkness of Peter and Victoria
oh yes everyone Victoria F is in the
final freakin three what do you think
right off the bat let me know in the
comments below as I reach for a glass of
wine don't you know today trying a new
rose a thank you a Francis Coppola the
diamonds collection perfect for us
sparkling forth again from the darkness
with a beautiful light Rosa let's do it
before we go to the darkness let's live
in the light love and light everybody
and there was a lot of love on this
episode Peter is down to his final four
head into hometowns and they're a bit
unexpected as we've discussed but Peter
says he feels great about this Final
Four I have the race for better left so
we got to go with it we got to support
our boy we're starting off with Hannah
and in Knoxville and her and Peter go up
to see each other and I gotta say was
their greeting a little a little bit
cold you know are you
how are you how are you how are you hey
have you been I'm good
lovely to see you they weren't speaking
with British accents but do you know
what I mean about the vibe at this point
shouldn't we be saying babe like babe hi
baby how are you I don't know let me
know in the comments below and they're
gonna go axe throwing to prove to Hannah
and Dad that Peter is tough you make
time for me you make me feel like the
only girl here now this was sweet just
as Hannah Anne wrote a list of 20 things
she loved about Peter last week Peter
has now written a list of 20 things he
loves about Hannah and things I love
about you but you know how easy is it to
come up with 20 things that you love
about something 20 reasons I love why oh
my god okay I did it
[Music]
I wish I had a pink piece of paper like
Hannah ended did she get that would you
have been honest with me every step of
the way what do you guys think of Peters
connection with Hannah and he says that
he loves she's been honest every step of
the way
you know I know that Hannah Hannah was
involved in the champagne gate drama in
the beginning but that was really more
instigated by Kelsey I think she's not
been a drama cause her you know
cheers to Ana a sweet lady we get to
Anna Ann's parents house and her mom is
really sweet she starts crying the
second she sees when you guys I got
chills Peter says this is exactly how
his family is it's so beautiful to see
Chris exactly on my family is like yeah
Peter we know barb Christ okay we know
sis do you wanna talk Jessica when I was
more captivated by in Hannah Ann's
family was her sister how do you feel
about Peter I mean it appears this girl
is watching The Bachelor so she pulls
Hannah an away and drink for every time
she was just ready with a question how
do you feel about Peter so did you tell
him you were starting to fall in love
yet and in 11 then you said you were
falling in my house he told you he loved
you have you said I love you just like
when you guys first walked in like and
then she just used the tears that woman
used her screen time unlike many of the
other one in this season okay I am
falling in love with her but back to
Hannah ends dad I am a big fan of this
man I'm speaking shortly here because as
he tells Peter don't waste a word don't
even waste a word yes he says do not use
the word love with my daughter if you
don't feel it wholeheartedly don't even
waste a word sir but peter has his words
ready and he says they are for short
words he tells Hannah and I am falling
in love with you
and that hands not gonna waste through
words [ __ ] comes right back with them I
love you I am we are getting done in
Knoxville what did you guys think of
this whole moment I actually loved
watching the emotion flood over Hannah
and space it was really beautiful and
cheers to that
cheers to emotions and clear
communication of those emotions using
the verbiage of succinct or tidge s
we're not going to get that for the rest
of the episode but as well as things
were going then Peter did scare me which
brings me to our deep emotional question
of the week which is Peter hears words
but does he care who speaks Peter wants
her to say I love you again and he says
quote it was great to know that someone
feels that way about you wanted is that
validation I've said it over and over I
just want someone to want me badly as I
want that what do you want
Hannah am a little bit tired of this
Peter wants constant validation from all
these women he's basing everything on
validation from each of them but he's
not giving equal validation in return so
is that fair sir why am I saying sir so
much today I'm feeling very British
because the British don't waste their
words at all do they you know the Queen
doesn't she had words for Harry and
Megan put in a statement
mmm-hmm how about that drama now let's
take our course over to Des Moines Iowa
and Kelsey I don't have a glass in my
head right now just horrible and cheers
to this she takes them to a winery in
boy I think you're gonna like it
something that you and I both enjoy
how are those grapes through the winters
what kind of wine are we growing in Des
Moines no shades at Des Moines but it's
not the best right I don't know if
there's great wine in Des Moines
somebody send me some Des Moines weina
okay its wine here we go instead of just
drinking wine I figured we could make
our own battle no way they're not just
taking in a flight they're stopping the
grapes that's gonna be a no for me guys
you know I don't want to work for my
wine I don't cook kid Weber was even
able to dance while stomping the grapes
I have two words this man cares downtown
there's the UM times but finally they
are cheering and you know what I'm just
gonna enjoy this moment
cheers babes oh and then Kelsey tells
Peter she loves him I am in love with
you
so much love we love it in the light of
day mmm and with wine oh and Peter says
he's grateful for the reassurance you're
honestly with me has been so reassuring
sure that cut to Kelsey's house with her
family and boy do I love them because
they are out drinking why cheers look at
all the varietals we had at the table
some people drinking red some people
drinking white some people drinking what
looked a heck of a lot like Rose hey
baby what's Kelsey's last name wait wait
we're we're Kelsey we're whatever cheers
to the weird stars and you know Peter
says he loves honesty so we're gonna do
a rapid fire big time drink for all the
honesty in these discussions first
Kelsey's mom says her daughter shows
emotions and I know my daughter it gives
her emotion and Peter's like yeah have
you seen that yeah Peter says I'm not
someone who gives up when the going gets
tough I'm not somebody gives up when the
going gets tough
yeah and then Kelsey starts crying an
inherent truth since the beginning of
the season mm-hmm she doesn't MIT that
she cries a lot I cry a lot a beautiful
self-aware truth cheers babe hmm what a
core work right now whining like this
next up it's Madison and Auburn Alabama
I have to say Peter does seem to light
up in kind of a different way when he
sees Madison
do you agree let me know in the comments
below like this was the greeting that I
would expect at hometown
[Music]
have a great time with the Pruett family
great a winery but now we're on a
basketball court they're in jerseys how
there's balls oh but that some man comes
in and I don't know who he is what goes
I don't know what his job is the
basketball coach but I really enjoyed
his energy very big smaller fives
cheers to that guy I'm Bruce Pearl
shares to Bruce hmm
is he the head coach the top guy head
coach
[Music]
cheers to roost the babe 200 pound ready
but then Bruce started making them
actually play the sport and that was
kind of upsetting mm-hmm and then he
left which was even more upsetting so
let's just fast-forward and drink during
the basketball
[Music]
and while we fast-forwarded right to a
747 because Peter says he has quote the
absolute best feeling in the world about
Madison the absolute best feeling in the
world about here the best feeling in the
world
I can't get enough of this girl you know
what guys I think we deserve a second
deep emotional question of the week
which is is Pete Weber buddy the elf you
did congratulations world's best cup of
coffee with her family doing the special
plate tradition what business let me
tell you about the special plate you
guys matters his family seemed to really
love each other and appreciate each
other they do something that I didn't
totally understand we're at dinner
somebody has the special plate so
tonight we chose Maddie and then
everybody tells that person how they're
special I like doing her such Oromo and
I thought it was very sweet I was just
wondering you guys do this every night
it feels time-consuming then again
what's a better use of time than
appreciating somebody who you love but
still what if you have commitments in
the evening well we're gonna start off
by praying so Madison this family's
talking a lot about Madison's faith and
their faith I thought it was really
interesting when her dad pointed out
they were cheering with sweet tea we're
toasting with sweet tea does that mean
Madison doesn't drink if it does no
judgment I just think something to be
discussed like how are you two gonna
conduct yourself socially in the world
together and then Maddie's talking to
her mom about saving herself for
marriage I am saving myself for marriage
something that definitely needs to be
discussed with Peter and still hasn't I
am falling in love with her but Peters
talking to Madison's skeptical dad and I
needed to be there for this Peter and
Madison's dad we needed a journalist in
the room you
follow-up question Madison's dad is
asking about Peters feelings how can you
assure me that that's genuine and Peter
says well if this was the last week if
this was the last week and then
Madison's dad cuts him right off if this
was the last week well obviously it's
not the last week if this was the last
week what you'd say you were in love and
proposed to Madison let me know in the
comments below this is not sweet team I
love math and don't waste your word just
say like because Madison only likes
Peter yeah she did not tell Peter she
was in love with him but drink for every
747 Peter does tell Madison and then he
tells her he loves her
these statements are getting so big
Peters now reading people's minds he
says he knows they're on the same page
yeah she's on that same page of me but
as we know Peter doesn't like easy
does he three yards Peter easy does it
yeah you know it's just not clear to me
why Peter felt he and Madison around the
same page and it's also not clear to
Peter that Madison's a virgin she still
didn't tell him that did she I wanted to
not waste my words there so I made
sounds instead
next up we've always been saying it's an
ad for sunset but now it's a V Victoria
is in me for Virginia Beach everybody
and me for a very kin dramatic so
everybody I just want to circle up and I
don't want to waste my words this date
is largely about one word awareness so
first cheers to Peter being aware
because he does seem aware of his issues
with Victoria F don't drink for
everything he sees he knows it's been a
hot and cold I know that our
relationship has been hot cold things
started dicey I kind of started off a
little dicey
they've had to deal with some stuff
we've kind of already had to deal with
stuff and things with Victoria EV would
never be boring a life with Victoria
would never be boring I mean sure
then again hurricanes aren't boring
being aware is the first step taking
action is the second you gotta be aware
and go from there okay now I do have to
give Victoria credit for this on their
date she surprises him with a country
concert and of course we know the last
time Peter surprised Victoria with a
country concert the singer was in fact
her ex of a questionable amount of time
is it one date or did the date for a
while we don't know she called him her
ex-boyfriend but he disagreed about that
but anyway it was chase price eggs as
though she was like remember when you
used to praise me by having my eggs sing
to us well now I'm gonna surprise you
with Hunter Hayes
you didn't date Hunter Hayes did you
[Music]
what do you mean you love him why would
you say that isn't your ex-boyfriend Oh
like you love him like you just took out
one time okay they're literally reliving
that moment they're redoing it maybe
this is a fresh start you know they're
dancing and we have so much footage of
people filming them on their iPhones I
really don't know why but you know it's
a rebirth they're dancing away the drama
Peter Webber is moving forward into a
place of love and light I then heard the
song because Peter says I don't want
easy
I want crazy I don't I'm very sure and I
just wanted cheers to the producers
because what a brilliant choice
so we're shooing away easy and we're
embracing crazy and then we're in the
eye of the storm because this woman
comes in and who is she
think seems so nice her and Peter seem
to know each other I saw you look so
familiar are you oh my god she knows
barb that was my mom you've been there
longer yeah she's a woman from Peters
past and she has something to say about
Victoria right yeah so we have learned
that her name is Marissa what did you
guys think of this moment
Marissa comes in and she's a woman that
Peter dated briefly years ago she tells
Peter that she knows Victoria F and that
he should he Elson says she doesn't want
to say why but then says Victoria F
broke up relationship there's been many
relationships broken off because of her
anything more than that and again Peter
you needed a journalist there ask the
follow-up question I just feel like if
you're gonna come in and make that big
of a statement about someone that they
are a person who breaks up other
relationships you've got to show some
receipts you don't have Spain you need
some facts you need some anecdotes you
need some experience that you can speak
to and Peter I wish he'd use more words
and spoken to a more and said to this
woman Marissa what the [ __ ] you talking
about ask for specifics okay I mean then
Peter says he's confused and pumpkin
cheese right now of course you're
confused Peter keeps saying that this is
a bomb that was dropped on him it just I
dropped I don't know if it was a bomb I
mean it was more like a sparkler more
like this maybe
so then if here's the victorious house
confronting her with the Bob she told me
you've caused a lot of other
relationships to end seriously in
Victoria's defense
how can she defend herself here Peter
tells her this vague statement and story
and she doesn't even know what she's
supposed to address or explain what
relationship does she say that I'd break
up she didn't give me details things are
confusing things are all over the place
we are in the eye of the hurricane but
as much as I'm defending Victoria here
then she goes back to her old ways
things turn toxic quite quickly she's
shutting down time she's crying I'm
sorry Fred each is just like all right
she's wandering off into the night into
the street get like it can't
Victoria be careful it's very hot out
there what is their cars every time she
comes back pretty quickly though because
they are there at her house and then
she's got to go home that's where she
lives so UK me right now that's just my
Ford from this like if you nephew
why not walking away by having a
conversation but so come and meet my
family tonight whose side did you guys
fall on here
I really did see Victoria's point Peter
was supposed to come meet her family
they were all waiting for him and then
instead he came in with this confusing
bomb to drop on her and that's
embarrassing I really feel in a
relationship no matter what you're
working through don't bring it into a
situation with other people family
friends whatever you put on a good face
and you talk about that later even with
the words exchanged it's confusing Peter
tells Victoria that she deserves to be
loved
beloved and he says goodbye it's feeling
pretty final and if I'm being honest I'm
hoping the needs of Victoria ever final
like finally done for goodness sakes
this is not good man she's back yes of
course these two are wasting their words
left and right Victoria EV shows up a
feet or so tell room I want to be
careful about how I say this I don't
think the Victoria F is Luke Keith in
totality but these two are the new
Hanabi and Luke P aren't they we can't
believe how far this has gone when we
all know that it's wrong even Peter
knows it's bad now he makes a big
statement a 747 he says they have no I
feel like we had no communications to go
in it communication skills oh my god
it's like a hurricane in this class just
a hurricane a wind coming at me but
Peter might not be as aware as I thought
look I'm not great at math you guys but
he says to Victoria f 99% of this is
amazing
99% of it that's amazing I feel it I
love it and 1% of this is not and that
1% it just like it terrifies me going
more like a 60/40 and the 60/40 is 60%
bad 40% sort of okay I know it's been a
minute since we had a case of whiplash
doors back in LA for a rose ceremony
so Hanna and gets a rose and that tracks
Madison Madison gets a rose and that
tracks and then drink during all this
awkward non eye contact eye contact
Peters not looking at anybody Kelsey's
not looking at anybody
Victoria ABS not looking at anybody and
she gathers Victoria
[Music]
drink for Chris Harrison's comforting
thumbs on Peters back
[Music]
[Music]
and Kelsey's going home what do you guys
think Kelsey says Bachelorette
I really have liked watching her this
season but not as super memorable egg is
it for me let me know in the comments
below
a 747 from back in the hangar though
appropriately Peter says that his wife
is in this hangar why am i flying the
plane like this there's a lot of
turbulence that makes sense my wife is
in this hangar with me right now and it
makes everything worth it but his wife
is in the hangar right now did anybody
knows but he seemed to be looking right
at Hannah Anna when he said that let me
know in the comments below
a pair of us will be like living
together awkward and now we get to live
in the light and do stuff in the night
for some of us we get to go to the
fantasy suites and oh my gosh you guys
the trailer peter says he's in love with
all three women I am in love with three
woman right now
and Luke B is back in our lives again
Madison says that if Peter has been
intimate with other women she's gonna go
I wouldn't be able to
go forward if you ask us with the other
woman one word whoa let me know in the
comments below I love you guys so much
thank you thank you thank you for
watching roses and Rosie we have just a
few episodes this season but I can't
wait to enjoy them with you so you too
have said that you're really into this
have you said you're falling in love
have you said I love you have you been
to the fantasy suites did you get a
blessing from her dad did you tell him
that you were committed did you give her
reassurance did you give him validation
what's your social security number
what's your credit score everybody
Monday's I made me think a hometown vlog
from my home it's so messy anyway
shameless plug we have a Hannah brown on
et's youtube series unfiltered this week
so I wanted to tell you guys to go check
that out she answers your questions
makeup free leg me right now
[Music]
you